est ce qu'on a vu au césar une réunion
de famille s'improviser sur la scène des
césar savoir si vous n'arrivez pas à oui
biensur et serait grave si je m'en
souvenais bah oui c'est ça c'est en 98
regardez pas comme ça
il s'en souvient pas emma de caunes
reçoit son césar du meilleur espoir avec
son papa sur scène on regarde
le césar est attribué à emma de côtes
[Musique]
emma de caunes qui n'avait jamais été
nominé
césar elle a reçu en revanche le plus
lumière 97 du meilleur espoir féminin
que d'un prix décerné par le public
qui pour rien rassure moi qui pour rien
mais la pression est extrêmement
émouvant ah ouais c'est fois que
j'aimerais vous y voir
non mais j'avais pas du tout imaginé ce
scénario mais c'est ça ouais mais tu es
banier elle va sans doute monter où elle
va la world je l'avais cochée pas mais l
on sait donc pas ce qu'on dirait son
dirai pas son père non antoine c'est
assez incroyable jeunesse éternelle
éternel adolescent s'est accompagné leur
daniel je sais qu antoine c'est aux
mêmes parce qu'il est john à l'extérieur
et vieux l'intérieur
[Rires]
conversation on connaît pierre tchernia
oui oui
on a vu antoine de caunes accueillir un
phoque de 200 kg sur scène bien sûr elle
te rappelles abbaoui 2011 franck c'était
un veau marin c'est vraiment une heure
moins de gros cailloux
big fucking funk
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abo
m
quant à la wrta l'impression qu'on j'ai
regretté pendant quelques jours
qu'il allait continuer à avancer
catherine deneuve juste
sera pas été bons à la pression pour
vendredi ou pas oui bien sûr vraiment
frustré oui du stress de la pression est
en fait c'est comme tous les spectacles
là on a à la fois le direct télé on a le
spectacle dans la salle on a tous ces
éléments qui peuvent partir envoyés à un
moment ou un autre donc c'est excitant
et stressant où après l'entrée ça doit
passer un peu denses et l'entrée une
fois ouais c'est dense à l'entrée la
prise d'antenne mais c'est ça la prise
d'antenne c'est puis c'est vrai que les
entrées des césar à chaque fois c'est
c'est extrêmement regardez c'est
extrêmement attendu c'est vrai qu'après
j'ai l'impression que tu après tu
d'études et roule bas après c'est comme
tout et voilà ça y est on est quoi un
mais c'est vrai que bon bah on attend ça
avec impatience tout cas vendredi est ce
qu'on a vu laurent lafitte savonnet et
bafouillé sur un discours pendant une
minute ça ça fait peur aussi en 2013 à
ce train là c'est du grand art ça ouais
très fort rien
le scénario c'est la colonne vertébrale
d'un film et la moelle épinière et les
acteurs qui en fait qui sent la moelle
épinière
et que sans la colonne vertébrale sept
mois c'est la moelle épinière que sont
les acteurs ne trouvera il ne trouvera
ne saurait pas où se situer
ce que l'aide globale de ce film ne
bénéficierait pas de cette moelle
épinière et il ne pourrait pas marcher à
lavaur
oui on peut rester petit effort ça le
talent et les sketchs des roms et en
envoie pas du oui oui bien sûr tu les
fais mon travail quand même bon avec
alou diarra qui comme en béton cette
année
c'est une bonne question et y en aura
plein d'ailleurs alors accusé il y aura
là j'ai pas le droit de dire son nom je
peux pas je peux pas je peux pas le dire
mais on dire non je peux pas je peux pas
chaud on va encaisser surprise mais ce
qui est intéressant avec laurent qui a
fait par ailleurs un excellent film
selatan et qui s'appelle l'origine du
monde il malheureusement des panneaux
mais il est laurent et l'excellence
avait à chaque fois sévir tout sûr qu'il
a quand il est intervenu sur la scène la
tour look et va faire un truc c'est
aller ou pas n'ont pas cette année ce
paraphe c'est pas grave on a tous les
ans pas tout mais on attendra un apr
l'année prochaine quand tu vas le faire
est-ce qu'on a vue caméra de glisser sur
la scène église oui
c'est une boule d'énergie et de bonne
humeur kad merad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ay la fin sous tu vois je le vois
vous disiez que c'est difficile parce
qu'à la pression les acteurs ils ont la
pression donc c'est difficile pour eux
ben justement moi en tant que
téléspectateur je prends un plaisir
énorme à regarder ça quand justement je
vois des acteurs que j'aime bien ouais
rigoler sourire et prendre du plaisir
quand je les vois rire c'est
communicatif je ris comme dit si eux ils
rient mais ces masses on a gagné en fait
c'est rachou le show en direct en plus
on attend ça et puis on attend pied dire
mais dans les césars il ya toujours du
team omlt ou ssd va se passer un truc il
va y avoir un mec qui va qui peuplent
qui va arriver sur scène il va devoir
attendre tu vas ouvre un gamin qui
mouillent sélectionnant qui va se
planter y est ça aussi qui normalement
tout arrive
c'est ça qui te fait peu nombreux non ça
fait partie du jeu ouais et plupart des
moments d'émotion s'est recueillie par
un délit at on pas hélas urbain antoine
tu as vu tous les films nommés il y en a
cent soixante et onzième je pense que
j'en ai vu sur 67 1 ouais ouais ça c'est
pas les chroniques
avait laissé ça
j'ai une vie dont son entourage et de ce
qui s'est produit en huit ans les gens
montent sur scène que je connaisse leur
film c'est normal ça c'est sûr mais
tient à 171,6 qu'ils envoient tous les
films ouais il a coffré
non sédentarisées oui c'est une
plateforme à quels conseils il va y
aller coiffer sa couperet toucherait
à peine quatre sets aux tours leader
oui quelqu'un voulait dire quelque chose
c'est moi non alors à 10h et aux données
non pas du tout merci c'est vrai danger
est ce qu'on avait omar sy se mettre à
danser en apprenant qu'il venait de
remporter le césar et c'était en 2012
record d'audience pour cette année là
avec antoine près de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs 18 2% regardez
merci à tous ces cons voté pour moi et
tous les autres ont été nommés
franchement je n'y croyais pas vous êtes
des grands les mecs donc je vais partir
mais juste avant
[Musique]
6 1
chez les pères comptage était jour je
m'en fous je suis ton haddad merci
beaucoup merci à tous
tout était là tout est là avec omar
c'est ça je suis hyper content j'ai fait
comme si je m'en fous
exactement mais c'est vrai qu est ce qu
a pas ceux qui n'ont pas eu des noms
mais moi je m'en foutais l'important
c'est que le film soit sorti oui les
remerciements bon là c'est génial mais
parfois c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit
ça s'étire en longueur est ce que vous
avez une méthode si jamais ça bien trop
long vous allez intervenir comment vous
faites c'est très délicat à jouer dans
la nature du remerciement t2 du propos
qui est tenue mais j'ai fait un tuto
cette année à destination de tous les
nommer en leur expliquant qu en une
minute de temps une bonne minute si on a
un peu préparé son speech et qu'on sait
ce qu'on va raconter on peut largement
tenir une histoire donc je leur ai
demandé comme une faveur d'essayer de
s'en tenir à cette minute après je peux
pas couper les jambes il ya du neuf à
soucis sont très dépendants parce que
vous dire que le truc c'est le truc mais
j'ai des musiciens sur scène
le truc du gong ou le truc du recsa
c'est toujours une mauvaise idée parce
qu'ils ont retenti et tu dois pas dire
mec oui c'est ça notre est mort en fait
c'est une taille le truc pour rien aux
haut-savoyards oscarisé à la musique
écrit par wendy la nec qui nous dit tu
sors toutes les deux mineures on en
train de parler d'ailleurs tu sors
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il avait envie de sortir